¿Qué es Qiskit?
Qiskit es un kit de desarrollo de software de código abierto
para trabajar con computadoras cuánticas
a nivel de circuits,
algoritmos y módulos de aplicación. Este SDK
permite que cualquiera programe en computadoras cuánticas reales desde
su laptop. Con dos líneas de código puedes acceder
a varios sistemas cuánticos, desde superconductores
hasta qubits de iones atrapados. ¿Quieres emular el comportamiento de una computadora cuántica?
Cambia una sola línea de código
y simula tus quantum circuits en nuestro simulador
de alto rendimiento. Qiskit es una herramienta usada por decenas de
miles de personas en todo el mundo que buscan
construir el futuro. Ya seas investigador, desarrollador
o simplemente quieras empezar,
Qiskit tiene una serie de
funciones disponibles para lo que necesites,
permitiéndote hacer cosas como
construir tu primer quantum circuit,
ejecutar algoritmos cuánticos de distintos dominios
y estudiar fenómenos cuánticos fundamentales.
Quizás ahora sea el momento perfecto para que te involucres
y encuentres todas las herramientas que necesitas,
incluidas computadoras cuánticas reales
y el SDK a través de Qiskit,
y una comunidad dispuesta a darte la bienvenida
y responder cualquier pregunta que tengas en el camino.
Puedes empezar hoy mismo
en Qiskit.